but you might have had a tough
upbringing you can extrapolate any
negative experience to give yourself a
shield against any new negatives if you
think to yourself none of this is nearly
as bad as my dad whipping the out
of me or Mom or whatever it is right the
point is like we've gone through
hardship all of a sudden it just gives
you a very different context of what
hard feels like what hard feels like is
the same whether it's a business heart
or an emotional heart it feels the same
I think if you can take these past
experiences that are hard before and
extrapolate them onto your current
situation you realize you've been
through so much more than this and then
you can look back and say like to use
the Morpheus quote from the Matrix like
I stand Here truthfully and Afraid not
because of the path that lies before me
but because of the path that lies behind
me